[Music]
this is the big moment where we tell you
where these beautiful bouquets came from
and remind you we bought them all on
saturday so they've all had a chance to
kind of perish under these hot lights
together and we're answering the
question what's better buying local or
buying online some of these are from
local shops uh one's from a store and
then a couple of them are from online
for valentine's day and now nate's got
the answers of which one is which you
can see the price is right here okay
nate so you guys did a great job
yesterday on guessing what the prices
were for all of these and it's amazing
from under 20 bucks up to 130 dollars
uh and this one is actually a pretty
smart deal by our intrepid shopper so
it's not just the roses in this case the
under 20 the roses were actually only 15
the mason jar is kind of the giveaway
because you got this one heather where
did this one come a little unique that
one's from trader joe's the flowers are
from trader joe's the vase or the mason
jar is from the family dollar store
so you put this together and you're
under 20 bucks and you're doing fine so
i think you guys thought this next one
was one of the online ones yeah we pay
online i'm gonna go pro flowers pro
flowers okay i'll i'll join that
close there was 96.42 that's actually
one 800.50
so i mean you know you're going online
you're going to get sort of the same
thing and one of the things that uh
sherry brought up a lot of us are buying
flowers for people out of state so
maybe you do the online or maybe you
find a florist near them and call them
up i should point out real quick these
flowers online you can see how much they
have they've kind of wilted away over
the course of the week compared with
some of the other ones oh yeah so maybe
the shipping wasn't factored there it's
not looking so good okay so this one was
the 8669 okay where do you think this is
from i'd say one of the local shops so
um henderson or vegas uh let's go with
but had so much greenery it is a
beautiful gorgeous existence
okay so here we are over on the other
side uh did you guys think this was
local or online this one in the back
yeah we were going with online okay so
that we're kind of getting into the
process of elimination
yeah
and that is pro flowers at a hundred and
two dollars but they're in a bad way
right now
well again you got to keep the water we
did add the feeding packets yeah yeah
all that stuff we did and so finally by
process of elimination the rose shack
again we've lost a couple of them here
but a hundred and thirty dollars if you
get it delivered in the next day or so
from whenever you order they'll last for
a little while and a nice thick bouquet
and again under these hot lights this is
you know unscientific but i'd say they
some of them held up pretty well there
it is the rose test is complete
hopefully you guessed reasonably close
and hopefully this will help your
shopping for a good time
this was a very interesting the
reactions were amazing so thank you for
all your responses hey i love this we